ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนผู้เรียนมวันนี้วันอะไร
คะวันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 6
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนมิถุนายน
ปีพตอะไรคะข้อศ.
2565 ค่ะ RE คศอะไรคะข้อ 2
ต.ค 42
3 ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะตอนนี้
บ่าย 3 เมื่อสองโมง 9 นาทีค่ะ
ค่ะ
บ่ายสามเนาะวันนี้วันที่ 6 แล้วก็
[เพลง]
ดี 6 ปุ๋ยเราต้องช้อปปิ้งไหมคะวันนี้ 6
เดือน 6
รุ่นช้อปปิ้งกันนะคะผู้หญิง
เขาก็นี้ใครค่ะหลักฐาน
ชายวันนี้ต้องมีโปรโมชั่นพบเดือน 6 หมู
คู่เรียมคูเรียมเป็นคนชอบช้อปปิ้งไหมคะ
คิดว่า
ชอบนะคะ
ผู้หญิงเรียนชอบชอบช้อปปิ้งไหมโอโหชอบมาก
เลยค่ะ
หนูผู้หญิงซื้ออะไรค่ะอ่ะน้ำพุเมื่อก่อน
เมื่อก่อนช็อปปิ้งบ่อยๆแบบ 1  1 อาทิตย์
ใช่ไหม 7 วันเนี่ยก็ซื้อของกับอย่างน้อย
ก็หนึ่งครั้งอ้าวมากๆก็ซื้อเสื้อผ้า
อะไรก็ซื้อเสื้อผ้านะซื้อเสื้อผ้ามากๆใช่
คูเรียร์มาคะ
เรียงก็
เมื่อก่อนไม่ช้อปปิ้ง
ตอนนี้เรื่องตอนนี้ก็ดูในโทรศัพท์แล้วก็
กด
จดทำได้จ่ายเงินเรียบร้อย
ใช่ค่ะเหมือนกันเลยเมื่อก่อนครูหญิงก็คือ
ช้อปปิ้งต้องออกไปเดินห้างแล้วก็ซื้อของ
ตอนนี้อยู่ที่บ้านหยิบโทรศัพท์แล้วก็ช็อป
ปิ้งบ่อยๆหมอเขาเรียกอะไรอ่ะเสียเงินเร็ว
มากกว่าเวลาไปเดินห้างอีกนะใช่แล้วผู้
หญิงนะคะผู้หญิงต้องจ่ายเงินเยอะๆเลยมั้ย
เวลาชอปปิ้ง
เยอะนะก็ไม่น้อยเนาะเพราะว่าเวลาเราทำงาน
เราทำงานใช่ไหมเราทำงานแล้วเราได้เงินเรา
ก็ซื้อของเนี่ยแทงขึ้นอย่างเมื่อก่อนเรา
ยังเรียนหนังสือ
ขอเงินคุณพ่อคุณแม่ก็ซื้อเสื้อ
99 บาท
199 เนี่ยหู
แพงไม่ซื้อแต่พอทำงานแล้วรูปเสื้อยืด 300
บาทโอเคนะไม่แพงเวลาทำงานแล้ว
ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงเคยจะซื้อเสื้อทิศถูกกว่า
90 บาทไหม
ไม่เคยเลยอ่ะเพราะว่าครูเรียมเวลาไปเดิน
ซื้อของอย่างเงี้ยเวลาไปจตุจักรไม่
จตุจักรเนี่ยจะขายเสื้อเสื้อยืดน้อยเสื้อ
ยืดแบบนี้มากๆแต่ที่จัดรู้จักกับค่ะเขา
ขายเหมือนราคาตามไซต์ท่าไซส์เล็กสะมุด
Size  S
xs  S อย่างเงี้ย im ก็ 1 ตัว 90 บาทพระ
L  XL ก็แพงนิดหน่อยแพงขึ้นแพงขึ้นผู้
หญิงก็เลยไม่เคยซื้อเสื้อที่ถูกกว่า 90
บาทครูเรียมเคยซื้อเสื้อ
ซื้อเสื้อนะคะถูกกว่า 90 บาทเหรอคะเคย
มีผู้หญิง
วิ่งมีด้วยหรอมี
คิดว่าน่าจะ 3 ตัวเสื้อ 3 ตัว
100 บาท
เฮ้ยทำไมครูจังรอเป็นเสื้อมือสอง
เสื้อที่มีคนใสแล้วแล้วก็คิดเบื่อไม่อยาก
ใส่แล้วก็เอาไปขายนะคะใช่ค่ะรูหญิงผู้
หญิงเรียมซื้อเสื้อมือสองแล้วหรอ
เฮ้ยครูหญิงไม่ซื้อของมือสองไม่ซื้อเสื้อ
มือสองไม่ซื้อ
โทรศัพท์มือสองไม่ซื้อซื้อรองเท้ามือสอง
ผู้หญิงไม่ซื้อของมือสองค่ะครูเรียมซื้อ
ของมือสองด้วยหรอเรียกซื้อของมือสองมา
แล้วบางทีก็ไม่ได้ซื้อด้วยได้มาฟรี
เลียมทุเรียนไปที่บ้านเขาแล้วก็ไปสอยมา
เหรอคะไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ค่ะครูหญิง
แล้วทำไมได้ฟรีเรียงก็เหมือนแบบรู้จักรู้
จักผู้หญิงผู้หญิงก็ใส่แล้ว 1 ครั้งแล้ว
ก็อ้าเบื่อก็เลียมเอาไหมก็เอามาให้เรียน
นี่
โง่แค่นี้เนี่ยผู้หญิงเฟ้ยก็ไม่ได้ซื้อ
เหมือนกันมีมีพี่สมัยมีพี่ที่เขามีเสื้อ
ผ้ามากๆ
แล้วเขาก็เบื่อแล้วใช่เขาก็เอามาแล้วเรา
ก็หาใช่ไหมหยิบอันเนี้ยเคยเคยแบบไม่ได้
ซื้อเนาะเคยใช้ของมือสองแต่ว่าถ้าไปเดิน
คะแล้วก็ซื้อของที่เป็นเสื้อผ้ามือสอง
กระเป๋ารองเท้า
อันนี้ไม่เคย
คิด
โอเคหรือเปล่าเสื้อมือสองมีคนใส่แล้วคน
นั้นฉันไหม
ถ้า
เราก็คือหญิงซื้อมาใส่ไม่โอเคไม่ซื้อผู้
หญิงก็ซื้อมาแล้วซักในซักแล้วก็ตา
มันก็มาใส่
คะถ้าเมื่อก่อนใช่ไหมเมื่อก่อนเนี่ยไม่
ได้ซื้อเสื้อมือสองนะเวลาที่มีคนเวลาเรา
เป็นเด็กๆเนอะเราก็แบบเราก็จะโตโตๆบาง
ครั้งเสื้อผ้าเนี่ยใส่ไม่นานก็จะมีคน
เนี่ยให้เสื้อ
ตั้งค่ามือสองกางเกงมือสองเวลาเอามาเนี่ย
ที่บ้านครูหญิงนะคะไม่ได้ซักอย่างเดียวนะ
คะครูเรียมผู้หญิงทำอะไรคะ
เราต้มด้วย
วิ่งไม่รู้ที่ที่ที่บ้านครูเรียมเนี่ยต้ม
ใหม่
แบบว่าเราก็จะมี
ไม่หรอคะนิสัยเราก็จะมีไหมเนี่ย
ปีมีเหมือนถังอย่างนี้ค่ะเราก็ใส่น้ำเรา
ก็จุดไฟใช่ไหมเราก็มีเสื้อ
ดีกางเกง
เสื้อกางเกงที่เป็นมือ 2 นะมือสองไม่รู้
ของใคร
ก็เอาเสื้อใส่ลงไปเอากางเกงเนี่ยใส่ลงไป
แล้วก็ต้มสมัยต้มแม่น้ำเนี่ย 100 องศาต้ม
ให้เดือด
ต้มๆถ้าเชื้อโรคใช่ไหมฆ่าแบคทีเรียฆ่า
ไวรัสชนิดที่บ้านครูหญิงนะแต่ว่ารองเท้า
ถ้าเป็นรองเท้าไม่ได้ไงร้องงานทำต้มไม่
ได้
รองเท้าเนี่ยมีค่ารองเท้าเบอร์ 2 ไม่เอา
คู่เรียมครูเรียมเคยเคยใช้รองเท้ามือสอง
ไหมอาจจะไม่ได้ซื้อก็ได้หรือว่าซื้อเคย
ซื้อรองเท้ามือสองไหมละเคยได้รองเท้ามือ
สองมาฟรี
แล้วก็ก็เกรียนว่าใส่ไหมไส้ใส่จนใส่จนมัน
ทำไปเลย
คุยไม่กลัวหรอหรอข้างในรองเท้ามี
แบคทีเรียเน้นๆ
อ้ะเหม็นหนิงจึงไม่เหม็นซื้อรองเท้ามือ
สองมาริมก็ใส่นะคิดว่าจ่ายเงินยังไงจ่าย
เงินนิดเดียว
หรอผู้หญิงอ่ะหมาที่เหลี่ยมซื้ออะไรคะมี
คอมพิวเตอร์มือสอง
อันนี้คอมพิวเตอร์มือสองเนี่ยครูเรียม
ซื้อต่อจากเพื่อนหรือว่าไปซื้อที่ร้านขาย
ของมือสองเตรียมไปซื้อที่ร้านขายของมือ
สองค่ะลูกคู่เรียมโอเคเหรอคุณเรียมไม่
กลัวว่าซื้อคอมพิวเตอร์มือสองแล้วก็ใช้
1เดือน2เดือน3เดือนแล้วก็แอดคอมพิวเตอร์
เสียหรอพี่กลัวหรอไม่ค่ะเดี๋ยวก็ไปดูตอน
นั้นเรียมรู้รู้เกี่ยวกับขอเบอร์ดีไม่ดี
ดีดีไม่ดีตอนนั้นรู้แล้วก็เลยมาอุ้ยนี่
ซื้อ
แล้วก็ใช้คอมพิวเตอร์มาประมาณ 7 ปีล่ะ
หนู
ฉาย
จะว่าคุณปิงก็เคยซื้อคอมพิวเตอร์มือสองนะ
แต่ว่าซื้อต่อจากเพื่อนเอ๋ยเพื่อนเนี่ย
เขา
เขาไม่ใช้แล้วน้องไม่ใช่ละมันไม่ใช่เป็น
คอมพิวเตอร์แบบอ่า
Notebook เหรอคะแบบ Top อ่ะไม่ใช่สมัย
มันเป็นมันเป็นแบบคอมพิวเตอร์ใหญ่ๆเดี๋ยว
ค่ะครูเรียมเกินเป็นคอมพิวเตอร์ตั้งต่อ
แบบนี้ค่อยยอม Google
ทรายค่ะมันจะเป็นคอมพิวเตอร์ตั้งโต๊ะแล้ว
ก็มีอีกมีเครื่องมันด้วยอ่ะบ้านยังไงล่ะ
เนี่ย
ที่เป็นสี่เหลี่ยม
ตัวใหญ่ๆใช่ไหมคะ
สายสายค่ะตัดต่อใช่มั้ยต่อกันที่นี่ใช่
เคยซื้ออันเนี้ยเป็นของมือสองแต่ว่าซื้อ
ต่อจากเพื่อนในจากเพื่อนรู้จักกันนะเคย
ซื้อแต่จำไม่ได้นะราคาเท่าไหร่แต่ว่าก็
โอเคนะตอนนี้คิดว่าน่าจะซื้อมามากกว่าถ้า
ปีตอนนี้ก็ยังโอเค
โอ้
ใช้ดูเป็นทีวีได้นะคะใช่ของมือสองเรียบ
คิดว่าดีนะเพราะว่าเราจ่ายเงินนิดเดียว
ชายก่อนไม่ชอบซื้อใช่ค่ะเมื่อก่อนอย่าง
คุยอย่างนี้ก็ไม่ชอบคือถ้าเป็นพวกเสื้อ
ผ้ารองเท้ากระเป๋า
เสื้อผ้ารองเท้าเหมือนกันเราก็รู้สึกว่า
มีคนใส่แล้วอ่ะไม่โอเคต่อไปต้มใช่ไหมแต่
ว่าถ้าเป็นแบบพวกเคยนะเคยไปเดินตลาดใกล้ๆ
กับจตุจักรเนี่ยเขาจะมีตลาดตอนกลางคืน
แล้วก็จะมีของมือสองมาขายก็ไปเดินแล้วมัน
จะมีกระเป๋าค่ะเป็น
เป็นกระเป๋าสะพายนี้มันใหญ่ไปหรือเปล่า
แล้วกลับนึงนะครับมันเป็นกระเป๋าแบบอย่าง
นี้ก็ได้
อย่างนี้น้องเป็นกระเป๋า
ค่ะเราก็มีสายเป็นกระเป๋าแบบสะพายข้าง
เป็นหนังนะเป็นหนังอาจจะเป็นหนัง
วัวเนี่ยโม้เป็นหนังแท้ๆใบใหญ่มากนะครู
เรียนแบบใส่คอมพิวเตอร์ได้จะเอา
คอมพิวเตอร์ใส่ลงไปได้หนัก Top ใส่ได้ใช่
ค่ะแล้วก็เขาขายเนี่ยคิดว่า 1,  200 บาท
ถ้าจำไม่ผิดนะมีแต่ผู้หญิงสมัยผู้หญิง
แล้วก็มีเพื่อนแล้วก็มีเพื่อนสามคนอันนี้
คนไทยคนไทยหรอคนนี้เป็นฝรั่งตัวเล็กฝรั่ง
เนี่ยเขาก็เห็ด
ใช่ไหมแต่ว่าคุณก็ก็สวยนะแต่ที่กระเป๋า
มันมีชื่ออยู่ไงสนมิสเตอร์
มิสเตอร์ไรดีอ่ะฝรั่งอ่ะอ่ะมิสเตอร์ชาว
สมมติสวยมีชื่อมีชื่อแล้วก็มีนาจนๆเขียน
ไว้ฝรั่งเลยบอกว่าโอเคไม่เป็นไรแต่ครู
หญิงเป็นคนไทยแบบไม่โอเคถ้าคุณซื้อแล้วก็
เอากลับไปที่บ้านมิสเตอร์เช้าอาจจะมาแล้ว
ก็แบบเอากระเป๋าคืนก็พี่บอกว่าไม่ซื้อ
รื่นเข้าไปรู้เรียมคุยกับเห็นกระเป๋า
เสื้อไหมกระเป๋ามือสองแล้วแบบทุเรียนชอบ
มันสวยมากแบบหนังแท้ๆเลยนะแล้วแต่มีชื่อ
เขียนเอาไว้คุณเรียนซื้อไหมคะ
ไม่ซื้อค่ะผู้หญิงกลัวรวย
ผู้หญิงก็กลัว
ก็แบบฝรั่งฟังเพื่อนใช่ไหมที่ไปด้วยเขาก็
แบบอะไรโอเคเออมิสเตอร์ชาวฮ่าๆๆแล้วเขา
เขาไม่เอาแล้ว
จะคุยก็คิดเราไม่รู้อาจจะมีคนไปขโมย
กระเป๋ามิสเตอร์ชาวมาก็ได้เราซื้อแล้วก็
เอากลับเต็มที่บ้านเวลานอนแต่อาจจะมี
เสียงเอาคืนมาเอาประเป๋าคืนมาเลยไม่ห่า
ถ้ามีสติ Shop พูดภาษาไทยได้นะ
จะพูดภาษาอังกฤษก็โอเคเนาะเราฟังไม่เข้า
ใจไม่เข้าใจใครพูด
เพื่อผู้หญิงซื้อไหมคะเรื่อง
ซื้อค่ะครูเรียมมเพราะว่าเขาเห็นแล้วแบบ
ชอบก็คือเห็นครั้งแรกเนี่ยก็คิดก่อนใช่
ไหมเดินแต่ถ้าเป็นผู้หญิงก็คือไม่ซื้อนะ
คะไม่ซื้อหรือว่าเฟอร์นิเจอร์ที่เป็นมือ
สองก็ไม่ซื้อไม่ซื้อเหมือนกันคู่เตรียม
เคยซื้อพวกเฟอร์นิเจอร์มือสองไหมคะ
ไม่เคยซื้อค่ะครูหญิง
แต่ไม่เคยซื้อเฟอร์นิเจอร์มือสองแต่ถ้า
เกิดแบบเป็นเพื่อนเอาให้เดี๋ยวก็โอเค
เพราะว่าหนึ่งแต่ถ้าไปเดิน
แต่ถ้าไม่รู้
โต๊ะของใครก็ไม่ซื้อใช่ไหมคะไม่ซื้อค่ะ
ผู้หญิงเรียงนึกขึ้นได้เลยว่าถ้าเกิดถ้า
เกิดกูหญิงเคยเห็นแบบเก้าอี้ที่แบบนั่ง
แล้วมันโยกได้มั้ย
ใช่ๆเจ้าอีโยใช่ในหนังไทยอ่ะเขาชอบแบบมา
ทำเป็นหนังผี
เราก็มีแบบนี้มีตั้งแล้วก็โยกเก้าอี้
ก็เลยคิดว่าคนไทยในหลายคนก็กลัวซื้อของ
มือสองกลัวซื้อเฟอร์นิเจอร์มือสอง
เขาแบบนี้ใช่ค่ะฟิล์มไม่ใช่ผู้หญิงรู้สึก
ว่าอย่างตอนนี้นะตอนเนี้ย
2022 คนไทยซื้อของมือสองเนี่ยมากขึ้นใน
คนไทยซื้อเสื้อผ้ามือสองกระเป๋ามือสองมาก
ขึ้นอ่ะฟุตบางคนเนี่ยขายของมือสองก็มีคน
ซื้อซื้อแม่เสมอคู่เรียมครูหญิงและเสื้อ
ยืดเบื่อแล้วไม่อยากใส่แล้วเอาไปขายมือ
สองก็มีคนซื้อตอนนี้ไม่คิดอะไรแต่ว่าถ้า
เป็นเฟอร์นิเจอร์มือสองรถมือสองบ้านบ้าน
เราไม่เรียกมือสองร้อนแต่ว่าเป็น
ป่าบ้านเก่าไม่ใช่บ้านใหม่ค่ะจนถ้าสมมติ
ว่าครูเรียมจะซื้อรถซื้อบ้านคูเรียนจะ
ซื้อของมือสองไหมอ่ะแต่
ถ้าเกิดเป็นของมือสองที่รู้จักว่าเป็นของ
ผู้หญิงเป็นของครู Arty เป็นของเคลื่อน
เรียงก็ซื้อนะแต่ถ้าเกิดเป็นของมือสองไม่
รู้
รสของไร
บ้านของใครไม่รู้ก็คิดคิดๆไม่สิทธิ์นะ
นะคุณก็คิดอย่างนั้นเหมือนกันน่ะว่าหนู
วัน
บ้านแพงเนาะรอรถเราต้องขับนานๆก็ขับไป
แล้วไม่มีเพื่อนนั่งอยู่ด้วยก็ไม่โอเคนะ
คะ
ผู้หญิงจะเอารถไปขายให้ใครผู้หญิงแบบจ่าย
เงินไปเยอะมากๆแล้วก็จ่ายไปแค่ 1 วันสอง
วันผู้หญิงก็เห็นถ้ามีคนนั่งซึ่งข้างเวลา
ขับรถ
ผู้หญิงก็ช็อคตายลงนั้นแล้วกูเลี้ยว
ช็อคตายเขากลัวแล้วก็เสียใจเหรอจ่ายเงิน
เยอะเทอม
ใจนั่นแหละหายก็แต่ว่าจริงๆในประเทศไทย
หรอการซื้อของมือสองมันก็เปลี่ยนไปและคน
ปัจจุบันนี้แหละเค้าก็ซื้อมาคือว่าอยาก
ทุเรียนมผู้เรียนก็รู้สึกว่าการซื้อของ
มือสองธรรมดาใช่มั้ยปกติใช่ยิ่งแบบของฟรี
ยิ่งปกติ
เอ้
ก็ชอบไงชายรอบของมือสองถูกกว่าด้วยใช่ไหม
ทำไมเราต้องซื้อแพงๆมันก็แบบมึงเปลี่ยนไป
แต่ว่าเมื่อก่อนคนไทยจะแต่ว่า Who เสื้อ
สะอาดไหมมีไวรัสแบคทีเรียหรือเปล่าซื้อ
มือสองมาใส่แล้วคันมั้ยเดี๋ยวเมื่อก่อน
เราจะแบบคิดมากไม่ไม่ค่อยทุกคนจะซื้อของ
ที่มันใหม่อะไรไม่ใช่มือสองเป็นของใหม่
เลยไม่มีคนเคยใส่
ใช่แต่ว่าตอนนี้หลายๆคนก็ซื้อแล้วก็ใส่ 1
ครั้งซื้อแล้วก็ใส่ 1 ครั้งหรือว่า
โทรศัพท์ซื้อมา
ซื้อมาแล้วก็อยากเปลี่ยนเครื่องใหม่ก็เอา
โทรศัพท์มาขายให้เรียมมาขายให้อื่นยังไม่
คิดว่าโอเคนะ
พี่ชายค่ะเพราะว่าบางคนก็รู้
ตายแล้วก็เหมือนกับซื้อของมือสองก็ดีกับ
โลกสมัยโลกของเราด้วยใช่แล้วว่าถ้ากูถ้า
ไม่ใส่แล้วก็ทิ้งก็ไม่โอเคไหนก็ให้คนอื่น
หรือว่าเอาไปขาย
นั่นแหละค่ะก็เป็นเรื่องการซื้อของมือสอง
ก็ไม่รู้ว่านักเรียนน้องนักเรียนคิดยังไง
กับการซื้อของมือสองน้ำคิดว่าธรรมดาโอเค
หรือว่าไม่โอเค
กลัวผีเหมือนครูหญิงกับทุเรียนม
ก็ไม่รู้เหมือนกันถ้าเกิดนักเรียนอยาก
แชร์ก็พิมพ์คอมเม้นต์ด้านล่างนะคะเราจะ
ได้รู้กันว่าการคุณคิดยังไงกับของมือสอง
ใช่ค่ะแต่ว่าวีดีโอนี้มันหมดเวลาแล้วหรือ
เปล่าคะเวลาแล้วค่ะคือผู้หญิงไปเจอกันใน
คลิปทันใหม่นะคะ
ทางสวัสดีค่ะวันที่ค่ะสบาย
ม.ค